make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're getting in the house of X
part 4 and here is the deal if this is
the fourth issue I don't even want to
see what the finales like like I don't
even want to know like do the finales
gonna be insane because this is Jonathan
Hickman this is amazing okay okay so ah
man whoever Trey something all right
here's the thing so so this initially
picks up with the other side of the
mission to the mother mold right we
talked about the mother mold being this
sindelle they would create other master
molds right it was a way to just
exponentially create a huge amount of
signals and an exceedingly short amount
of time
what this does is where you have the
x-men launching the mission near the Sun
at the old Dyson Sphere as it was
created by Tony Stark during Hickman's
run on Avengers and New Avengers what
you have here is you have storm and
you've got magic and you've got Xavier
and you've got magneto who are
communicating with them from Earth from
the other side and that's the big
question that's asked here because one
of the cool things that goes on is you
actually see a kind of melding of minds
coming together now this is not uncommon
what's going on here is they're
basically daisy chaining everybody
together right so you've got magneto
you've got beasts you've got a storm
you've got you've got magic got all
these different characters gathered
together and all their minds are going
to link telepathically and they're going
to communicate with Jean Grey and the
reason why is because this is an
astronomical distance for the most part
I mean given the entire scope of the
universe it's stepped out the front door
but in terms of the distance between the
Earth and the Sun it's a huge amount of
distance especially for characters
trying to communicate telepathically
remember when you're talking about
someone like Charles Xavier somebody
like Emma Frost and Jean Grey without
the Phoenix force
they're basically earth-based telepaths
right they can't really communicate to
people on other planets that's really
reserved more for somebody who's in
possession of like the mind stone from
the Infinity Gauntlet or something like
that and so it really does take all this
mental energy to be able to pull all
this off and to be able to communicate
with Jean and what we end up finding out
is that when the bomb was detonated by
aggregor the head of security at the
time that basically it's caused absolute
havoc for the x-men right like they
ended up losing Ark Angel and husk right
so both those characters are dead like
it's crazy to see arcane will just die
like that but it's it's it gets crazy uh
like like here's the funny thing about
Wolverine when I first looked at this I
was like did Jonathan Hickman really
show Wolverines arm being cut off
because he has adamantium if you look
close enough there's a bone it's like
his arms not actually cut off it's just
mangled really bad but basically like
the the x-men team this field team is
hits
pretty much been decimated that's kind
of a crazy thing because Hickman is is
sort of looking at this and saying okay
how can we make situation dire for this
right because if you go when you look at
almost anybody's x-men run outside of
Chris Claremont Chris Claremont would
have done this this is exactly what
Chris Claremont would have done he would
have had the x-men go on this ship he
would have had the people on the ship
respond and in kind and then he would
have shown the x-men decimated right
like just their ranks not really all of
them being massacred but certainly all
of them being like severely injured or
something like that you don't really see
that in modern day like he it's it's
it's kind of crazy you you look at
certain things and you see it from time
to time but you don't really see it see
a scenario where it's like okay so this
is basically the last stand of the x-men
you never really see that and it was
kind of cool to see Hickman doing this
showing us how dire things really are
for the team but at the end of the day
the mission has to go on and so when the
question is asked of you know of Jean
Grey you know I guess asked of all the
other x-men through Jean Grey who's
being communicated to by you know
professor xavier using the minds of the
other x-men on earth can the mission go
on the response of Cyclops is yes now
this is where Jonathan Hickman shines
when it comes to writing Cyclops and
this is where Cyclops fans get their
Duke let's talk about this for a second
let's talk about Cyclops Cyclops fans
have really just kind of been screwed
for like the last few years or so and I
understand where they're coming from
because well I'm not the most hardcore
fan of Cyclops I am a fan of the x-men
my my favorite x-men like my favorite
well I'm not gonna tell you my favorite
x-man is I want you guys to guess who my
favorite x-man is I'm curious to see if
any of you guys can get it right ah
because it'll be it'll probably be and
it probably end up being like a crazy
guess if anybody gets it right I'll be
amazed but nonetheless like Cyclops fans
have been left hanging over the years
right because like Cyclops was killed
and like they got the crappy young
Cyclops from the Ben destrun and nobody
wanted him that character sucked people
wanted like the old-school Boy Scout
Cyclops and it was cool to see his
characters evolve man right where he
went from being like the guy who always
believed in the Xavier streams or the
guy who basically became the new Magneto
like I love that version of his
character but Cyclops fans have kind of
been screwed and this is a great moment
because this is a tribute to the Cyclops
fans because during the old-school Chris
Claremont era and even during like the
stand the the Stanley Jack Kirby era the
Roy Thomas era the Arnold Drake era
Grant Morrison you go to Chuck Austin
you go through like all of these
different eras of the x-men and this
this is classic Cyclops and it's the one
that people have really wanted to see
come back for quite some time because he
is the guy who would say we're all
probably gonna die here but so long as
the mission succeeds that's all that
matters because more important than
anyone
man is the mission and the mute the the
future a mutant [ __ ] that's what I love
about the character of Cyclops and so
ultimately he basically says we're gonna
split up we're gonna go to different
locations right we're all gonna go to
different sections and we're basically
gonna destroy these giant devices that
are holding the mother mold in place
right because the idea is to release
those devices and the mother mold will
just go crashing down into the Sun and
that'll basically be the end of it and
it's pretty cool the way it happens
right because then you've got the wife
of Gregor who we talked about in the
last video you got her who's basically
freaking out because her husband
sacrificed his life and so witness when
this happens she's basically told look I
can't really order you to do anything I
can't really tell you what you can and
can't do but what I can say is if you do
nothing then your husband sacrifices
life for nothing
so do something because it's the only
way to really redeem your husband's
sacrifice here and so that's when this
battle is fought on two fronts because
on the surface we would say okay it'd be
a silly move for her to go after the the
x-men ship that's basically attached to
the mother mold you know mother mold
satellite it would make a whole lot of
sense because none of the x-men are
really there but what it does do is that
gives them a place to basically retreat
you and possibly an out or a place to
make their last stand her response is
get rid of it scuttle the ship so
they're stuck here there's no way for
them to get back - and it's kind of cool
because remember Nightcrawler can't
teleport that far
Nightcrawler can't teleport from like
the earth to the moon or something like
that
his powers aren't that aren't that
developed but within the timeframe that
it takes for Gregor's wife you know the
scientist to basically communion figure
out what is they want to do two of these
brackets are deactivated they've got two
more left and it's kind of crazy and it
gets super cool because what it does is
it switches back over to the ship itself
and then it picks up with Monet st.
Croix now of course we've explained
Monet saying Troi in the Generation Next
video so I'll link that down in the
description but she's basically two
people in one that's really what it is
with her but she also does have like
that crazy penance look right when she
went I think is when she becomes penance
it's her history is so crazy and so
murky the reason why they did what they
did with with her was because they were
trying to find a way to make Generation
X relevant going into like everything
after issue number 21 and so like it
didn't work she was cool for the time
but like nobody cared about the money
st. croix the long and short of it is
she's exceedingly capable right so I
mean she literally puts Jean Grey in the
in the escape pod and then scuttles the
escape pod sends it flying out into
space and basically says like she's
gonna take everybody else on her own and
of course she's completely destroyed
this switches over to mystique and this
blew me away
right because mystique goes into that
one section they chose mystique for that
area because she can shape-shift why
she can just look like one of the
scientists the issue is as soon as she
gets in she's met by the doctor's wife
and what this chick does is open up one
of the open up one of the airlocks and
suck mystique out into space right so
mystique is gone like she's dead and
it's just like like dude they're fallin
do they're dropping like flies man like
the extranet is dropping like flies and
it's the craziest thing right because
like from there like it's basically
Hickman telling us like it's the last
stand right because what the what the
scientist ends up doing is she brings
mother mold on line now this is a
dangerous game because remember with
these sentinels they are technically
designed to be characters that have an
artificial intelligence right now their
artificial intelligence can't really
deviate past its own programming which
really kind of seems to be a like it
doesn't relie seem to make any sense
right it kind of seems to just be a
direct contradiction with itself but
it's basically this idea that it can
think and function within the realm of
its programming the issue with this is
they don't know how its programming is
going to going to like evolve and grow
right I mean like you're talking about a
computer system so all this thing needs
to do is come online and in the span of
seconds lose this mind destroy the
entire ship and then who knows what
would happen after that that's the fear
they have they don't know if it's going
to be sane or if it's going to be insane
if it's going to be like I am mother
mold I make Matt I make master molds and
that's it or if it's gonna be like I am
mother mold everyone's gonna die like we
don't we don't know that's what's gonna
happen we don't know if that's gonna be
the case or not and it's a gamble but
the crazy thing about this is that with
mother mold coming on in ten seconds the
x-men have to disengage this last device
right but the issue is at the open
airlock is on the other side which means
they have to find a way to get out there
deactivate it to shut it down and then
leave and it all comes down to Wolverine
it's the last stand of Wolverine and
this is the coolest thing ever because
if there's anything that Jonathan
Hickman is good at it's sending
characters out on one hell of a Bank he
is amazing at doing that right like it's
heated at during during the Fantastic
Four he did it during Avengers and New
Avengers like he did it during all these
characters like like you guys remember
from New Avengers and New Avengers when
Hyperion and Thor died oh dude dude was
a craziest thing ever II was like dude
like her period was like we're gonna die
here today and Thor is like yes but if
we're gonna die we're gonna die a
Warrior's death you know and it's like
it is the craziest thing Hyperion's like
he's like I will see you in Valhalla and
Thor's like brother today I will race
you there they just go like racing up
against these beyonders they get totally
obliterated it's like it's like there
was a crack of thunder and something
else and then silence and it's just like
oh
my keys man it was it was insane like it
was one of the coolest things hickman is
so good about that
right because Buin up having this
conversation between Wolverine and
Nightcrawler and and and Wolverines is
kind of like do you think there's
anything for me after this like like do
you think there's anything in the
afterlife waiting for me it's a
vulnerable wolf ring right because the
way that Hickman writes it is kind of
Wolverine covering it up with I'm just
sort of curious but it's not he's kind
of like I'm gonna die here like I'm
gonna die in this place there's no real
way for me to come back I'm gonna be
stuck out in space I'm gonna be
incinerated by the Sun there's not gonna
be any way for me to return from this
it's so like do you think there's an
afterlife for me and it's the cool is
this one of the coolest most touching
moments because Nightcrawler tells him
when you wake from this earthly slumber
my friend I will be there waiting for
you radiant and with open arms and it's
just like like from that point he
teleport teleports Wolverine out there
right because like Nightcrawler burns up
when the Sun he's got to go there to get
Wolverine to that location so
Nightcrawler burns up in the sun's heat
Wolverines skin is literally melting off
of his off of his adamantium skeleton
which is gonna be the only thing left
and he's just like hacking and slashing
away there's think manages to destroy it
and falls into the Sun falls into the
Sun with the mother mold and he's like
it's one of the coolest things as that's
happening he's so like slashing away at
mother molds face as he crashes down
into the Sun it's the most badass thing
I've ever seen in my life
Jonathan Hickman Jonathan Hickman
writing it's the craziest thing because
from that point then it picks up on
Cyclops trying to make his escape
Cyclops is shot in the back the
excellently the nanites end up
travelling through his body and into his
brain and it's a craziest thing because
when he's basically saying what he's
talking to the scientist and he's like
it's like Hatchery me doesn't mean
anything her response is we're not
capturing anybody today you guys killed
my husband you're gonna die and and
Cyclops gets shot in the face and dies
all the x-men sent on this mission die
every single one of them die it's the
craziest thing ever because now what we
get and this is this is this is gonna be
a sight to behold now what we get is the
wrath of Charles Xavier and the wrath of
Magneto and I am hype to see what that
looks like what that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys have a sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
you